oh man could you could you imagine that
dog at the g7
[Laughter]
at this weekend's western conservative
summit florida governor ron desantis
edged donald trump in a 2024
presidential preference straw poll
it's not really straw cat so sit down
former vp
mike pence came in 10th and if you could
see the look on his face right huh
actually it's the same look he always
has but anyway desantis is one of
america's most popular governors thanks
to his wins on florida's economy and
covent response
he's also a fighter and that's
connecting with new republicans who are
younger
rowdier more populist and more racially
diverse the story in politico magazine
argues that
the barstoolification there's a word of
the gop could reconfigure its cultural
politics for a generation
barstool ahead dave portney who enjoys
tormenting liberals online has ranted
against covid lockdowns
threatened to punish employees for
attempting to unionize and even
announced a presidential campaign
and if trump exposed anything it's that
libs are the party poopers
the pearl clutchers who can ruin a party
faster than a backed up toilet
don't i know it and since the left has
the federal government the school system
the corporations the media big tech
voters are in search of real change and
are looking somewhere else
you know it's like george washington
once said to his wife martha
i crossed the delaware so why don't you
take out the garbage old bag
it's one it's in one of his earlier
memoirs cash
a lot of people don't remember that part
but i do
uh cash uh is it too soon to care about
this tough or is it too late
to care about this stuff well
having worked for president trump and
knowing governor desantis well i think
they're both going to be awesome so let
me just say that
over and over again yes now i can get
down to it i don't pay much attention to
like the denver disco poll
four years out ahead of time because all
the polls got it totally wrong
true four years ago five years ago plus
i think if you were in the mix
you would have finished one point ahead
of pence oh i think so too and i haven't
ruled myself out
i haven't talked to myself about it i've
been wrong i'm putting calls into my
into my office but i'm not returning my
own calls i can run with you
you could run with me i would i don't
know um i think i need a woman of color
you're a racist
yes i am a racist who just assumed his
gender by the way yes or her gender oh
my god
they're gender they're gender how dare
you mispronounce him
and i think you might have dead named
him did you dead name him or did you
deadpool you're still seeing him
i don't know it's it oh
my god what am i doing kaylee i have i
am the most disgusting
bigoted person at this uh now my
mother's calling me
what do you make of this do you think
that like desantis is a strong
strong person trump could pretty much
make it or break it at this point right
he could decide on him or decide to
challenge him
he could and i think that right now
desantis is even edging
out trump because he's in such a great
position right now
this year and you know three years from
now that could be a very different story
right now he has
great success record on kovid one of the
only governors
to do that and um you know he's weighed
in on just about every policy issue that
republican voters really care about
he's sending border assistance to texas
in arizona
he's weighed in on woke genderism
critical race theory you know all these
issues that are really taking over the
republican conversation right now
he's making waves right now but i do i
agree that i think it's a little bit too
soon to just definitively say
this is going to be our guy in 2024
unless trump decides to run
and he hasn't taken a stance on shark
attacks which i think is a big deal
okay here's a crazy option i don't know
who to ask this to
because i want to talk to you about bart
okay i'm gonna here's
this is not my idea okay but this sounds
like a great idea
that trump runs for congress in florida
and then when you take back the house in
2022 he becomes speaker of the house
well that's he doesn't even have to run
for the house to become speaker of the
house haven't you heard
that's what they were saying they were
saying well anyone could become speaker
of the house you could
i could why are you always putting me in
the middle of this mix cash
yes what do you what do you make of this
well he's already been the president and
knowing what we know about him would you
see him
like taking a lower seat even if it was
this sort of 40 trust me i don't know if
trump is that kind of uh
yeah yeah yeah uh but i i mean i was
wrong the last time so i don't want to
weigh in on what's gonna happen but
rhonda said he's like you know he's
he's america's daddy now he's not yeah
america's governor everyone loves him
yeah he's like the democrats
he's like the reverse cuomo everybody
andrew cuomo was supposed to be
america's daddy
but he ended up being america's devil
united 9 america's devil
he's bizarro world cuomo yes exactly
yeah
here's an idea canada just came up with
this now uh um
chadwick is right that uh trump will not
go for a
job that's smaller than the one that he
had why don't if they create a job
called
greater than the president and it's like
it's like so
it's like so then trump goes i'll take
that job
you mean you mean like a king yes didn't
we fight a war about that
i didn't fight that war i kind of like
the idea of having a king
wear a big robe i'd like to be the fool
i wanted to hang out there and just make
jokes all the time and
pray that they don't kill me okay well
answer the question cat why are you
evading the question i think i did
answer the question i don't think we
should have a king
no i i i don't want a king you worked at
barstow i did i worked at bar stool
i am a a woman yes okay hard to believe
i know
crazy because i i really do exude
masculine energy
yes but um i had like every time i read
these articles about barstool and like
this horrible place it is for like women
i'm like
i just don't it blows my mind because i
hate to you know burst anyone's bubble a
lot of people hate barstool
i had nothing but the most wonderful
experience the entire time that i worked
there
and to the extent that dave portnoy is
political it's
really only in the lens that democrats
set up absolutely
they spent four years making their
entire party platform basically
trump says offensive stuff and he can't
say that
and if you don't fall in line with that
then they see you as a political
opposition because
every time someone said oh you can't say
that portney would just say okay
watch me and a lot of people find that
really refreshing
well portnoy didn't politicize sports
that was somebody else so now what
happens is if you don't play the
political game
in entertainment or sports or anything
holidays
you're also a political animal and you
can't even step
out of it you can't even you if you like
bar stools is about as political as
as i don't know as insert can you insert
something in edit
uh with a little joke about it's you
know something like that thank you
whenever you read these articles i'm
like what are they talking i i was there
and it wasn't that yeah but granted you
were drunk the whole time cat
only some of them hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else